apple roared into the the tv game
with a morning show a superb drama yeah
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity
and doing the right thing made by a
company that runs sweatshops in china
so well you say you woke but the
companies you work for i mean
unbelievable apple amazon disney if
isis started a streaming service you'd
call your agent wouldn't you
so if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything
you know nothing about the real world
most of you spent less time in school
than greta thumburg
so if you win right come up
accept your little award thank you agent
and your god
[Applause]
i so like uh i feel like we're all
gearing up for the greatest war of our
generation
right iphone versus android
dude i am so sick of iphone versus
android just use what you want and shut
up about it
who cares what phone you use as though
hating on someone else's phone is going
to make your phone better
right i got this friend he uses an
android right stupid [ __ ] he happens
to use
android he happens to use android and if
you just mention
the words iphone around him right just
mention the words iphone
he just starts losing his [ __ ] right oh
my god the iphone
the iphone sucks look at my android just
getting stronger with the hate
look it's like the dark side of the
force just unlocking
new abilities
the iphone sucks rise android
stupid just use what you want shut up
about it who cares what phone you use
like remember when the iphone 6 came out
remember iphone 6 came out that guy
released a youtube video of the iphone 6
bending
over that look at this everyone look at
this iphone 6 bends look at this if you
do this to it
it bends what a piece of [ __ ] this is if
you do this to it
it bends yeah no kidding deep [ __ ]
oh who would have thought that if you
use
all your strength to bend an iphone 6 at
its weakest point
it breaks who knew
there goes my plan to build a bridge of
iphone 6s
just no structural integrity whatsoever
in fact while i add it look at all this
other [ __ ] around me that can bend
easily with my bare hands pencils and
spoons everything's bending
i would not imagine you being so tech
savvy i really are you
into technology you know yeah
some of it is too much you know like i
have a i don't have an iphone i had an
iphone and it's too it's just so
absorbing you just it's just like having
a pencil that can
you know i just i just want to write
something down i don't want a whole
panoramic experience
and i think that i think people are a
little naive about what they're giving
away because it's like people are so
excited to have geotags
that there's a company that always knows
where you are like what are you
nuts yeah and and there's some new thing
in the cloud
they want you to go to the cloud and
they're selling it as a great idea
just you don't need your stuff just give
it to us we'll keep it on the cloud
it's fine you don't have to and you're
like really but those are my pictures
and my
just give we'll keep it on the cloud you
pay a little rent
to have it up on the cloud and the way
they're going to talk you into this
is that you get to have a smaller device
because you don't need to keep the stuff
on it you know
that's why okay like this somebody gave
me this iphone this is where an iphone
is right now okay
now it's gonna when they when they tell
you you want to keep it on the cloud
they're gonna say this is this is the
iphone now the off the next iphone
is it's just gonna be this that's good
and it's just gonna be this thing
because you need this to store all your
movies and stuff
but you're just gonna have this and you
just rub and go oh i wanna see tom
cruise and he'll just
tom cruise will be all around your face
and then you wanna see you know selma
hayek and then you take it and you and
you
that's how it's going to work i'll give
you 10 000
for that thing right now
actually nerd jesus died in the last
year right
steve jobs yeah he died right
i know i know a lot of nerds here
tonight i know you're sad
i didn't get it i didn't get the big
deal they made about that guy
when he died they were like he changed
the world
doesn't say he changed the world
the world was one way and then steve
jobs came and it was another
what did he do somebody for the love of
god what the [ __ ]
did that guy do what did he do he told
other people what to invent i want my
entire music collection
in that phone get on it
right and then these poor nameless
faceless scientists got to go in the
back room and figure it out
what the [ __ ] are we gonna get all of
this into this i mean
what year does this guy think this is
this is crazy this is like buck rogers
dude my kid has a birthday in like 11
months
steve jobs just walking by i don't hear
any thinking going on in there
just strutting around the office eating
some pretentious fruit like a pear
right just throwing out ideas
there's another one another one i just
came up with on the way to work
i was reading a magazine the other day
turning pages you know
i'd like to turn pages on the screen
that aren't even there yeah wrap your
[ __ ] heads around that guys
see you in eight years where you going
michael big little big little get on it
right then all these people slave away
to make his vision come true and then
they have the big nerd fest right
down there comic con and all their nerd
mecca they are all showing up with their
acne
and their hulk shirts limping into the
arena
right the steve jobs go out with the
whole chorus line of scientist now he
goes out there by himself
sneakers and no belt like it was no
biggie right
[Applause]
like he's like he's tesla
tapping into the atmosphere i know this
is always uncomfortable i know
you bought into it right that whole
advertising the way they aligned
themselves with some of the greatest
people of all time
jesus gandhi me
remember that muhammad ali john lennon
this guy
how the [ __ ] was that dude like any of
them
gandhi didn't have a sweatshop
ah he didn't have people leaping to
their deaths only to get
catch a net and get ricocheted back
through the window
to have to put together yet another ipad
john lennon didn't have children in his
basement pressing those
[ __ ] albums
i know i know
new phone can't fit the old charger this
is your hero
this is the guy this is what all the
silence is about
new phone can't fit the old charger so
then you got to throw it out ends up in
the ocean around some octopus's neck
do you realize how much sea life is
ecstatic that that man is no longer
walking the earth
that's where it all ends up you know it
doesn't go to landfill ends up in the
ocean
you realize that i hate people who say i
don't pollute i don't pollute yeah you
do
you use [ __ ] you throw it out what do
you think is you put in like a basket it
just poof disappears
everything he ever used is somewhere you
ever think about that
remember that flannel shirt you bought
back in the day when you got into pearl
jam
that's out there somewhere probably on
some porpoises face
trying to get it off stupid little
flippers
all the fads remember rollerblading
remember that everybody had him we set
up cones we did little tricks right
one little homophobic joke killed that
entire fact
what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents
you're gay
full-grown adults dude i'm not gay i
don't have the cooties these mean i suck
dick and they just threw them out
[Applause]
they end up in the ocean they're made
out of plastic they can't biodegrade
they just break down the little cubes
fish are breathing them in
six months later you're going out you're
getting sushi you think you're being
healthy
you're eating your old rollerblades all
right i'm out of time you guys are great
thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
from now on when i take off on the road
no more phone calls
look at that guy yeah are you here by
yourself
dude anyway
here's the thing i took my girl to the
apple store and i got her an iphone i
got myself one and i said from now on
we're texting each other and believe it
or not she was cool with that because
anytime she would send me a text i would
reply like that
i could be anywhere freaking in the
bathroom freaking
what are you doing
i'm blowing it up i love you sam
and she replied oh my god me too i love
you
it sounds so stupid but it was working
out perfectly until one night i got
drunk
oh you want to hear this you want to
hear this
so check this out i'm leaving a comedy
club in san jose california
and i'm walking back to my hotel room
which is one block away
as i'm walking i pass in front of this
bar on the corner called
cnet bar it's got all kinds of cinema
and movie memorabilia in there it looks
cool
i'm walking in front and there are
people in that bar that just left my
show so i walk in front and i heard
fluffy hey let me buy you a shot
i was like well you know i don't want to
be rude
can't have that right so i walked in i
said what's it you know i'm on my way
back to my room i just do a couple shots
whatever so you know one shot and then
somebody me two
all right me too i'm gonna let's do it
me three me four
15 shots of tequila later
[Applause]
it occurs to me i think i should go
i start walking towards the door i took
three steps the cold air hit me
i got dizzy and i fell hard i know i
fell hard because when i hit the ground
i farted
oh i got it my buddy martine ran over
and he helped me up off the ground
are you okay here okay we stumbled back
to the hotel room i sit down in the
lobby and i'm just like
are you okay gabriel i'm okay man
where's my phone i gotta let my girl
know i'm okay you're holding it oh thank
you martine i love you
i love you your girlfriend man you're a
girlfriend
because what are you doing i'm a text
you just call her no
if i call her she's gonna know
something's up i'm gonna a texture watch
baby i made it back to the hotel
i love you
sand how
did it go i farted
i shouldn't tell her that okay it went
good what did you do
after your show oh here we go
my buddy martinez like cable man gabriel
don't tell her don't tell you at a bar
getting drunk man
don't tell her martine i have to tell
her the truth bro
we're cool like that man i could talk to
her
i could i could tell her anything man
she's not like you're old lady you know
[Music]
tripping all the time hey martin take
the pictures out of the coaching
off the internet whatever i'm sorry did
i say that out loud forgive me bro
gabriel lied i can't lie man lie i can't
lie
are you that honest no i just won't
remember the lie
i get in trouble two times for the same
stupid thing you know what i'm saying
bro
so i sent the message baby i made it
delete delete delete baby
i went next door with martine
to cena bar
had a nice time kissy face kissy face
kissy face send
clean lucky you wish i could have been
there with you
tell martin i said hi i love you
oh my god martin i just told my
girlfriend i was at a bar with you and
she didn't get mad
what the hell is she doing
man she told me to tell you hi and she
don't even
like you so i scroll back to read what
she read and apparently my stupid iphone
has this memory spell check feature
and it didn't recognize the word cena
bar
it flipped it and turned it into
cinnabon
so apparently at 10 o'clock at night my
girlfriend thought i was having cinnamon
rolls with my friend martine
which normally would sound like an ugly
lie but considering her boyfriend is
known as the fluffy guy who loves
chocolate cake
it sounds real i was like oh my god
martin check it out my iphone lied for
me
blackberry can't do that